things 13 year olds need to understand
you have the dream but you have to
execute patience bro patience I would
literally give up everything I have to
be 15 years old save money and learn if
somebody at school is taking the time to
tell you that you're ugly you suck
you're stupid they're in a very bad
place the best way to deal with that is
compassion try as many things as
possible until you figure out what
you're rad at and you like and go do
that for the rest of your life and stop
giving about everybody else learn to
love to lose I Love Lucy here's why I
appreciate the experience of that loss
my friends if you're thinking positively
good things are going to happen if
you're thinking negatively bad things
are gonna happen go home cut your losers
lose your friend and go find a winner
friend doing good for other people is a
good strategy you are living in the
greatest era to be alive because you
have the power of the world in your
pocket the hardest thing at this age is
to be you and not let other people's
voices into your head to factor into who
you should be if I could wish all of you
one thing besides help I would wish you
self-awareness